hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the meltwater Champions Chester
finals 2022 now it's not as suspenseful
as we thought it would be since Magnus
won the tournament uh with a full with a
full round spare uh he he won it in the
previous round and uh the the match
against The Duda is the one that we were
really looking forward to as their games
can also be really explosive and I
decided to show you one game from the
match it is the second game of the match
our first one ended in a draw was a
pretty much uh in an equal game
throughout the entire game uh but second
one is uh well a bit different now
before we check out the game and it is a
really nice one uh I would just like to
address one
um I think that a few videos ago I I
told you that someone sent me a message
that I was mispronouncing uh aduda's
name Yang sheet of Duda and uh well that
person obviously tricked me and then a
lot of you guys sent me an email with an
actual recording of your voice as you
are from Poland uh how to pronounce his
name but one gentleman even sent me
there is a on chess.com when you create
an account or maybe it's just for Grand
Masters or very well-known players
there's actually uh an audio file where
you can listen to Duda himself
pronouncing his name and he pronounces
it like like I do pretty much or I try
to reproduce it to the best of my
abilities but it obviously it is very
very close to Yang shustov Duda so I
will be sticking to that just in case
you were wondering now getting back to
the game do that with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to C4 yeah he goes for
the English opening with g6d4 and Bishop
to G7 we have Pawn to E4 and now D6 we
have Knights the C3 and C5 striking in
the center D5 Duda grabs more space in
the center and now Bishop captures on C3
now this is a very very uh strange move
in a benoni type structure because your
your dark Square Bishop is usually your
most powerful piece but I've seen
similar lines before
and the Magnus uh does go for it even
though out of all the moves this is the
the least played one so Bishop captures
on C3 B captures and Ponte E5 so what
did Magnus just do he gave up one of his
Bishops into one of his stronger Bishops
uh to close the center completely and
the double do this C pawn and in on the
other hand Duda has a semi-open b files
that he can use for his Rook he has The
Bishop's pair and he has a very clear
way of what he wants to do he wants to
push F4 he wants to capture on E5 uh
hope for D captures on E5 he will try to
create a past the d-pawn and that's
basically the uh well the the simplistic
version of it so Bishop to D3 continuing
development and Knight to D7 we have
Ponta F4 striking against the E5 Pawn e
captures an F4 Bishop captures an F4 and
now Queen to H4 with check we have
Bishop to G3 and now Queen to E7 putting
pressure on the E file Knight to F3 and
now Knight to H6 and here there is a
game where castles was played and uh
probably you should play something like
this or even just develop the queen to
D2 maybe go after that Knight but Duda
goes for the immediate E5 and it is now
as of move 12 did we have a completely
new game and this is a very very tricky
variation as you'll see so Magnus says
all right that looks like a free Pawn
I'm gonna capture it Knight captures an
E5 Knight captures and not D captures on
E5 and here do the just castles we have
Castles by Magnus and now Queen to D2
putting pressure on dead Knight on H6 so
Knight to F5 and now Bishop captures an
F5 yeah even though you have the bishop
pair the light Square Bishop isn't
really useful here uh it's better to
keep the dark Square bishop and try and
take advantage of all the dark Square
weaknesses around magnus's King so
Bishop captures an F5 Bishop captures
and now Rook F2 preparing to double up
on the F5 we have F6 by Magnus now
creating a very strong Center here
D5 Pawn is nicely defended but Duda on
the other hand has a passed the D Pawn
so Rook a to F1 and now Rook 8 to d8 by
Magnus now he could also consider
something like Rook F7 and then maybe
doubling up on the f file he goes for
Rook to d8 instead and now Queen to E3
yeah also maybe you could consider a
move like Bishop to H4 uh but uh this is
of course the rapid so you players have
to play very fast you do the goes for
Queen to E3 puts pressure on C5 Magnus
defends it and now Bishop to H4 putting
pressure on this diagonal so Rook to D6
and now Pawn to H3 now it's a very close
position and it's hard to uh actually
push something so Magnus moves his
Bishop back Bishop to D7 and now he
wants to start advancing his pawns so
Rook to F3 we have Rook the F7 and now
Pawn to G4 we have Bishop to E8 by
Magnus and now Pawn to G5 putting a lot
of pressure on that F6 Pawn forcing
magnets to advance it further Pawn to F5
and now Rook back to E1 we have E4
Bishop to G3 now this is uh the only
good move dude that has in the position
and it's a very tricky one uh because if
magnets were to trade here let's say he
captures an F3 Queen captures an E7
captures and Rook captures on E7 after
Rook captures an E7 uh sorry not rookie
two you have to root captures on E7 both
the Magnus is a rook and D6 and Bishop
on E8 would be hanging and if you defend
it with Rook to d8 okay you've defended
your pieces but now Bishop P5 going for
Rook G7 it's a very very hard to play
against it is and you still have to
worry about the past deep one you have
to play Bishop F7 and then you lose the
A7 pawn and it's just uh a really bad
position for Magnus he he would struggle
to find the move here so instead after
Bishop G3 Rook back to d8 and now Rook
to F2 uh we have Bishop to D7 and now
Bishop the C 7 attacking the roof maybe
with some ideas of the advancing the
pawn to D6 but you have to be careful
once you push D6 you no longer control
C6 and E6 Square so Rook to E8 and now
we have Queen to F4 adding a Defender to
that Bishop like I said if you push this
right away then you give up these two
squares to the atom Magnus then he can
even put a bishop on C6 so maybe not
something you want to do so after rookie
8 we have Queen to F4 and now Bishop the
C8 the bishop can be shifted now to B7
or even to A6 if needed uh here we have
Bishop to D6 attacking the queen queen
to d8 and now Bishop to E5 and here
Magnus uh could try a lot of things of
course do this plan is to put the bishop
on F6 but Magnus is not interested in
that he just plays a rook captures on E5
and this is where he says that uh all
right uh the two Rooks aren't very
useful here none of us can push any
pawns but if I give up my Rook for for
your spectacular dark Square Bishop as
the bishop was about to control this
entire diagonal and you would probably
have to capture it at some point even if
the bishop land on F6 so he gives up the
exchange captures captures and now Queen
captures and G5 snatching upon while
he's at it rooked G2 and now Queen back
to F6 Magnus offers a queen trade now
and uh you you should really not accept
this so Queen to B8 dude I put some
pressure on the bishop here Rook defeat
defending the bishop and now Queen back
to F4 and now Bishop to A6 Magnus goes
after the C4 Pawn Rook to E8 is also
very strong you just prepare Queen to E5
and then white either trade trades
queens or moves the queen and then use
the continue pushing so uh Bishop day
six visible Magnus played putting
pressure on the C4 Pawn Now Pawn to H4
with Bishop captures and C4 and now Pawn
to D6 with H5 uh you probably have a bit
more time to to attack the black king
after D6 it's not easy to play this with
white now Magnus plays Queen captures on
C3 we have rooked the E3 attacking the
queen and queen to D4 now putting
pressure on The Rook here so H5 uh we
had Bishop to F7 now guarding the G6
Pawn twice and the King to H2 and
pinning so now the Rook can move Rook
the d8 and now Rook e to G3 dude that
brings everything into the attack Queen
captures on D6 and now Queen captures on
F5 as the G Pawn is pinned Rook to E8
now ready to push the past E Pawn and
now age captures on G6 H captures and
how do you play this well the problem is
you can't really do something like Rook
captures uh on G6 just yet because the
king is on H2 it'd be great if you could
but you can't so King to H1 you have to
unpin first king to G7 and now Rook the
H3 we have Queen to E6 offering a queen
trade and here Duda finds a a very nice
move that can only be beaten if Magnus
finds one move that uh that that is even
stronger than that move uh so Queen to
H5 and now it's Magnus the move there is
only one good move for him to play so
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out how to get out of this mess
while I give you a couple of seconds
sense
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the the
simple trade and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
captures on H3 that's the only way to
stop any any checks along the H file uh
Queen captures on H3 and The Rook to the
rooked h8 now winning back the queen uh
there's no way to defend you have to
capture so Queen captures King captures
and now uh yes you have a rook against
the bishop but Magnus is up four pawns
imagine if you were up four pawns that
would be spectacular so Rook to D2 and
now worship the C for getting ready to
push that E Pawn uh Rook to D7 and now
okay going after the A7 Pawn but now a
Magnus just captures an A2 we have Rook
captures on A7 Bishop back to C4 and
King to G1 and now Bishop D3 now he can
start advancing both the C pawn and the
E Pawn with Rook C7 C4 Rook to B7 Ponta
C3 now Rook captures and B6 Pawn to see
to Rook the C6 now guarding the queening
square and pawn to E3 we have rooked the
C8 with the check King G7 we have King
to G2 and now Pawn to G5 King to F3
attacking the E3 Pawn Now Pawn to E2 and
King to F2 so now Roku guards the C1
Square King regards the E1 square but
who will guard the G1 square that is the
question so Magnus advances the pawn to
G4 King to E1 Now Pawn to G3 taking away
both F2 and F1 squares from the white
king and now there is nothing for you to
do if you if you move the Rook or even
if you start checking the black king the
blacking will just go down the board
doesn't really matter you'll just push
G2 and after King F2 now okay the king
is overloaded you will just Advance one
Pawn to become a queen and then you will
uh get uh get another queen so do the
tries Rook captures on C2 Bishop
captures King captures and now look at
this there are many ways to finish this
game but Magnus finds the most uh
Spectacular One and that is Bishop to D1
with check this is how Magnus finishes
finishes the the position now if you
capture the bishop the king is too far
away to stop the pawn from becoming a
queen and if you don't capture the
bishop the bishop covers F3 the pawn
covers F2 your only square is F1 so King
to F1 and now Magnus would play Bishop
to F3 cutting off the king from reaching
the pawn uh indefinitely would have to
go all the all the other way around and
then you would have all the time in the
world to advance your opponent uh to
becoming a queen and it's very simple to
actually win this now all of these
squares are not available to the to the
white king you can just move back and
forth like you can go to G1 and you can
go to to E1 okay and then maybe you can
go to to D2 but what what will you do
there and the black king will simply go
all the way here uh push G2 G1 and win
the game that's the the simple way to do
it so yeah after Bishop to D1 do the
resigned and a brilliant brilliant
victory for Magnus Carlsen in round two
of the final round of the meltwater
champion Chester Finals game three where
Magnus had the white pieces again ended
in a draw and uh last game the fourth
game where Magnus again had the black
pieces ended by Magnus win winning that
game so he wins both of his games with
the black pieces and he wins the match
3-1 which is uh pretty pretty awesome
and more and more people are just
winning with the black pieces like this
is not the first time we see this and so
I don't forget the standings these are
the final standings of the ml for the
Champions Chester finals uh let me just
make that a little bit bigger uh there
you go all right so it's uh first place
Magnus second place Wesley so Liam Lane
in third with with 11 uh young she used
to do that with 10 pregnant and the
argument and Anish giri with six points
and look at this Magnus which 20 points
in first place second place Wesley with
13 and Liam Lee in third place with 11
and now if you if you just do this look
at this again if you if you remove
Magnus from the tournament it's uh it's
a fairly close tournament I mean anyone
could have taken this but then you add
magnets to the tournament and then it's
well it's it's basically a one-man show
uh sure uh that's the game uh and the
short coverage of these multiplayer
Champions Chester finals hope you guys
enjoyed that if you have any game that I
didn't cover and that you particularly
enjoyed maybe I've missed it maybe it's
really a spectacular game to use hashtag
suggestions so I can go over it and
maybe I will review it uh but if not we
are uh turning to some other events as
there are so many events being played
nowadays I already have a couple of
suggestions from the world team
championship so we are going to look
into at that as well uh but yeah that's
the game I really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Francis air
Carmen polifrron Sinister Pawn revision
reptiles YouTube B4 and AI mind for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing uh to check out on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day